parque nacional mesa verde viviendas y
acantilados de nativos americanos mesa
verde está situado en colorado eeuu
localizado sobre un altiplano 2.600
metros sobre el nivel del mar este sitio
fue descubierto en 1888 por un ranchero
local él estaba buscando una vaca
desaparecida cuando descubrió estas
viviendas de acantilado por pura
casualidad
varias casas bien preservadas fueron
construidas dentro de una cueva en la
cara de un enorme acantilado y esta
agrupación de viviendas fue construida
por el pueblo ancestral pueblo dónde hay
más de 600 viviendas de acantilado y la
mayoría fueron construidas durante el
siglo doce piedras suaves fueron
cortadas y amontonadas para crear más de
150 habitaciones
estas viviendas pueden llegar a la
altura de 3 o 4 pisos y puedes apreciar
en ellas que troncos fueron colocados
dentro de las paredes para crear vigas y
techos y colocaban escaleras a la
entrada de cada habitación pues la
altura a cada puerta era bastante
considerable ahora vayamos a la cocina
esta es el área de cocina comunal maíz
dulce fue molido por estas rocas para
cocinar y también hay rastros de que
aquí también se utilizó el fuego para
cocinar
y este por el espacio donde se almacenó
agua agua de lluvia penetraba la blanda
roca de arena hasta llegar y acumularse
en este sitio
mesa verde es extremadamente caliente
durante el verano y cuenta con inviernos
muy fríos con nieve los primeros
exploradores le llamaron mesa verde
aunque el término correcto es cuesta no
mesa por su leve inclinación estas
viviendas de cavernas fueron
perfectamente adaptadas para proteger a
los pobladores de estas temperaturas
extremas y el severo clima gruesos muros
de piedra protegían a las personas del
calor del verano y bloqueaban los duros
vientos del invierno en las rocas hay
hoyos que forman rutas para sostener los
pies
los pobladores solían escalar las
paredes del acantilado
los pobladores de mesa verde vivieron
ahí por aproximadamente 200 años sin
embargo al final del siglo 13
de repente abandonaron el asentamiento
después de 30 años de sequía la
primavera secó por completo y los
pobladores se vieron forzados a
emprender un nuevo viaje en la búsqueda
de otras áreas donde si hubiera agua